[Applause]
olivia rodrigo hit the mtv video music
awards stage for a camera smashing
performance on sunday night the good for
you singer who performed at the vmas for
the first time arrived on a disco ball
like cloud where she sing her heart out
to the breakup anthem from her debut
album sour rodrigo rocked out pit of
screaming fans in an all-female band
included
[Music]
[Applause]
it was a lot of firsts for the 18 year
old singer at the vmas olivia who was
nominated for five awards was a winner
before the show even started she snagged
her very first moon person for best push
performance for her hit driver's
[Music]
and license was awarded with one of the
night's biggest honors song of the year
for the now infamous track this is so
insane um
wow okay uh first of all i just want to
thank all of you guys the fans this is
so incredible
this is the most this has been the most
magical year of my life and it is all
because of you guys so thank you so much
the good for you singer also made her
vmas red carpet debut at the barclays
center in brooklyn new york she turned
heads in a strapless fuchsia in orange
versace gown and capped off her gorgeous
look with butterfly earrings e.t spoke
with olivia in may where she talked
about her album and how the music
industry has welcomed her with open arms
sour is definitely like a slice of my 17
year old heart it was you know
i wrote about everything i was feeling
and going through and you know all the
insecurities i was having and all
feelings of sadness and anger and all of
these things that you know i don't often
like talk about in my daily life but
it's so fun and i get to sort of express
that in my songwriting so it definitely
was therapeutic i
love writing
a sad breakup ballad i
literally i wrote like breakup songs
when i was 12 years old and i didn't
have a crush on anyone like i'm obsessed
with them
um but i'm really proud of
this sort of diversity and sour i've
just been really touched by the way that
so many um you know
more established artists have really
welcomed me into the music industry and
gone out of their way to welcome me um i
think it's just like a really a
testament of how kind they are